some of the most recognizable
superheroes spider-man
Wonder Woman Captain America were
created by American comic book
publishers Marvel and DC those are the
like the two iconic brands for
superheroes but we never ever hear about
popular superheroes in other countries
ladies and gentlemen tonight we're
changing that get ready to meet some of
the biggest superheroes from around the
world it shouldn't just be about America
it should be about superheroes
everywhere in a piece we've left over
from comic-con called foreign
superheroes
[Applause]
first up from Bogota Colombia he fights
crime all day and all night and somehow
never gets tired it's capped in South
America give them a hand
[Applause]
next he's an incredibly even-tempered
guy who flies into fits of rage whenever
he's assembling IKEA furniture
it's the Swedish Hulk
[Applause]
Barnett's superhero is from the Middle
East and her power is her incredible
amount of freedom in a very closed
society she has the ability to drive a
car all by herself without a male
chaperone
it's the Saudi Black Widow
[Applause]
he's got a driver's license that's hard
to do next with grease on the brink of
bankruptcy they need a hero now more
than ever it's the Greek god whose power
is the ability to make all money
worthless say hello to not doing so well
Zeus
[Applause]
get that guy some cookie Kevin
he's still not all the way gone he's
still not all the way gone there he goes
what a sad guy alright next though
technically not a hero he is the only
Canadian supervillain
please welcome lex luthor's much nicer
more reasonable brother from Canada
Lance Luthor
if my demands aren't met within 24 hours
I'll rephrase them more politely sorry
about that
a
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally the Armenian superhero who
knocks foes unconscious by releasing a
thick cloud of our money cologne it's
mister mister
you smell gold it smell good everybody
smell good now God that's his
catchphrase
he's gonna take a while to walk away
look at him let's get hit and Zeus out
come on let's get hit
[Applause]
Zeus is over there back home
get them together
[Applause]
what you doing
that's good okay he's got his
Thunderbolt back things are looking at
for Zeus wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]